alors j'aime j'aime pas l'idée que jean
michel mr écrive un livre sur la
séduction
gilles verdez est-ce que vous pouvez
nous redire ce que vous avez dit juste
en je trouve que c'est dégradant pour
l'image de la femme il ya des termes
comme sudoku cul te vostro émirats qui
dans le contexte actuel me semble
inapproprié
non c'est une blague j'espère que même
si c'est une blague je peux rien prendre
après il ya des gens qui n'ont pas aimé
on va demander sur twitter ce que vous
en pensez
voilà au moins ne rit pas avec tout
voilà avec un livre sur la séduction
jean-michel le principal intéressé
j'aimerais qu'il doit déjà gérer gilles
que je ne veux pas du tout pour ce qu'il
a dit j'apprécie toujours son
franc-parler en cure en argent mais ce
qu'ils pensent voilà point bas bon j'en
ai souvent dit la semaine dernière avait
défoncé ma pièce de théâtre que t'es pas
venus voir et là tu défonce avocat n'a
pas encore lu un moment fou quand même
essayer de garder un peu la célèbre
question
le bouquin en lui-même en l'occurrence
c'est un bouquin qui a plein de second
degré à bouquin pour les ados et pour
les plus grands pour les jeunes hommes
voilà qui se veut vraiment plein de de
rigolade de trucs et astuces de
prévention situe t cha tout un chapitre
sur le sur la prévention sur les
préservatifs et c'est donc c'est pas un
bouquin comme tu peux le penser mais
grade en au contraire tu es toujours
nantais toi que les hommes veulent
toujours s'acharner sur les femmes pas
du tout s'ils trouvent une seule famille
sic et qu'elle est proche des reproches
à me faire dire je vais manquer de
respect je serai ravi
je vais aller à parler donner ça parce
que je manque de respect aux femmes
un constat que je puisse dire ça voilà
donc je dis ça sera temps de voir le
livre tu me diras ce que tu en penses
assez franchement c'est un livre qui est
un livre de rigolade
si on peut plus faire d'humour un peu
potache faut arrêter la pêche aux
salorges ils augmentent pendant un temps
je chéris va vous le vouliez donner
votre avis vous d'accord ou pour avoir
croisé jean louis quelquefois en soirée
about généralement crois ce qu'on soit
des gens mais on sait que ce soir et je
suis moi on a forcément voilà de
réputation de mec est louée et j'ai du
coup rencontré un jean mis très
respectueux et beau donc non non c'est
honnête
dire cela j'ai c'est pour rigoler je
connais depuis une dizaine d'années
jean-mi jamais vraiment il n'a manqué de
respect à une femme voilée l'ont trouvée
chez quelqu'un vraiment le jouer en vrai
je suis lourd il est mort voilà il
dévoila mais les lois avec tout le monde
c'est le problème géraldine valant parce
que vous vous êtes l écrivaine
oui donc vous vous avez envie de lire le
livre de jean michel maire ou en tout
cas j'ai envie qu'il existe sur ce
projet d'accord de l'interdire ce sera
absolument absurde en fait jean michel
mr namory se prend jamais au sérieux
ouais c'est comme si on mettait dans un
shaker un peu de coluche un peu de aldo
maccione et un peu des valseuses un peu
d'un an qu'on va 30 énormément en
cliquant du promu bon c'est peut-être un
peu plus raté que tout ça non mais en
tout cas ça se prend pas c'est en fait
le danger et c'est pour ça que je suis
pas du tout d'accord avec gilles verdez
ce serait de mettre tout sur le même
plan en faveur de parano ambiante et de
judiciarisation de tous et le ballon ce
ton corps c'est pas pareil que balances
ton dragueur c'est pas mal pareil que
manon son livre lous balens lourdingue
et il faut pas tout mélanger et c'est
pour ça que ça ce serait dangereux de
tout mélanger
je vis avec ça d'accord les noms parce
que le débat est biaisé vous cherchez à
me faire dire que je trouve que
jean-michel manque de respect aux femmes
c'est pas ça le propos j'ai pas dit
qu'ils étaient présents demain
j'ai dit que les profils que je vois en
fait deux chapitres de ce livre sont
honteux disgracieux et que c'est un
livre que je dis mais c est ce que tu
sais ce que le sudoku et toi pourquoi tu
sais moi je criais bourdy voir ce
critère me déçoit vraiment
[Rires]
ap